un débat que je trouve assez triste pour
notre pays ce qu'on a un grand pays
comme un grand pays on a de belles
valeurs qui sont enviées dans le monde
entier avec de beaux principes qui sont
universels permettre à chacun de s'y
retrouver quel que soit son origine sa
croyance son histoire personnelle c'est
ça la france c'est l'histoire de la
france avec des valeurs qui sont des
valeurs de la république et de la
laïcité et qui semble aujourd'hui
bafoués piétiner mais j'ai envie de dire
parce qu'ils se prétendent élu de la
république puisqu'il ne sont pas
respectueux de cette loi et ils veulent
effectivement la détourner la dévoyer
comme les islamistes veulent des
voiliers l'islam ils veulent des
voiliers la république et il s'auto
alimente les uns et des autres à partir
d'un terreau qui est celui de la haine
du côté des islamistes c'est la haine
qui tu es deux côtés des extrémistes
politiques telles que nous les avons ce
soir encore sur le bateau mais peut-être
qu'on les a régulièrement aujourd'hui
sur tous les plateaux télé sur toutes
les chaînes info on n'entend qu'eux on
ne voit que la réalité soit invitée
parce que mine de rien il faut arrêter
tous les gens les envies de cpe qui
viennent ici pas dire qu'on les a
invités pas je dis simplement que ces
gens large aujourd'hui haïti car j'ai
écouté tout le monde avec beaucoup
d'attention et de respect et je pense
qu'il faut qu'on décrit ce que le débat
et qu'on arrive effectivement à
s'écouter sinon benoît pas avoir quelque
chose de l'efficace et de constructif je
dis qu'aujourd'hui il ya des discours de
haine qui s'alimentent on ne partage pas
mon idée ou un partage
moi ma conviction aujourd'hui c'est que
les islamistes qui ont la haine et qui
tuent au nom de la n2 s'alimentent
aujourd'hui et alimente un discours
d'extrême droite qui est celui de la
haine de l'autre de l'exclusion de la
discrimination donc et aujourd'hui on
est pris en otage dans ce débat qu
elques et le débat de la haine alors que
nous avons des valeurs
nous avons des principes et je suis
effaré de voir que des gens sur des
plateaux télé à l'aise dans leurs
baskets mais vont aller à l'encontre de
notre loi nous nos lois à tous mais noah
qui s'impose à tous moi j'aime mon pays
pas parce que je suis né français
j'aime mon pays parce qu'il est porteur
de valeurs et de principes et je
considère qu être français ça se définit
pas avec une carte nationale d'identité
c'est une adhésion à des valeurs comme
ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné on vit
ensemble qu'on respecte des règles qu'on
respecte des lois comme partage des
valeurs et ça ne nie pas ce que nous
sommes
ça ne nous oblige pas faire preuve
d'amnésie des histoires de chacun
bien au contraire la france est grande
parce qu'elle nous permet d'être ce que
nous sommes rattachés à un lien naturel
mais aussi de nous dépasser
nous nous transcender et aujourd'hui
j'ai le sentiment que les discours
d'exclusion que le discours
d'élimination prennent le pas sur cette
république et cette laïcité moi j'ai
envie de vous dire une chose
ceux qui aiment pas la république et la
laïcité il faut qu'il quitte la france
mais voilà faut qu'ils aillent vivre
ailleurs et c'est vous mais pas ce que
je vais vous dire la république et la
laïcité aujourd'hui la république et la
laïcité dont elle permet la france a le
permet de s'appeler jambes et de changer
de prénom sur le souhaitent
c'est son droit monsieur mail permet de
s'appeler karim d'être fier de son
prénom et de ce sera une surprise c'est
une histoire de la réparer les
canalisations
[Applaudissements]
il faut surtout pas la remettre en cause
de moi je vous dirais tu vois moi
justement qu'il a eus je m'en tiens à
vous avez des amis j -p
moi je suis né en france une avignon à
ses pas dans la cité des papes
j'ai grandi avec des italiennes des
portugais des espagnols tout ça c'est
julie lui ni des musulmans des
catholiques des athées
mais je vais vous dire nous étions
heureux on était contents on se définit
sied pas par musulmans juifs et à calmer
mais cas aujourd'hui car aujourd'hui
genre vous définissez les gens par leur
origine non pas du tout la dinde et
déterminé mais je vous dirais secours je
l'avais dit rich et de l'éclairage à moi
si j'étais une femme musulmane je
porterai pas le foulard
bon alors mais c est ce que parce que
moi vous irez pattes parce que moi
nous le dit pas sûr aussi c'est bien
khadija d'accord si je peux terminer mon
palais si je peux terminer mais je ne
répondais mais c'est bien de 2,2 de
décompresser tout mais le débat mais la
réalité c'est que j'étais en train de
dire arrive si j'étais une femme
musulmane au nom de mes convictions je
ne porterai pas le foulard mais au nom
de la laïcité qui est une règle de mon
pays la france
madame a le droit de l'énergie commenté
madame au nom de sa liberté de
conscience assez pour ses attendus la
lie les trois noms de sa liberté de
conscience vous à l'école vous avez
s'est pas arrêté là d'accord pour des
contrées l'attenté des gens mission de
l'école on est pour ou contre la loi
karim moi je vois là mais c'est vrai
qu'à l'école on n'a pas droit l'unccd
les sentir il on arrive et irina falconi
les amis c'est l'écho elle est
enseignante mais non mais non les anime
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui moi
jouent pas d'une question mais ici
essayez pas de me choquer répondait est
ce que la loi de 1,5 à ce que des règles
de notre pays aujourd'hui tel que sont
édictées permettent à une
accompagnatrice d'accompagner les
enfants où aller oui oui veut changer la
loi alors pourquoi mon 8e pas l'école va
aller à l'essentiel